tutti per lei superchallenge sicuramente
la conoscere tutto
in pratica è un casco una sorta di casco
in cui dentro e si può mettere l'acqua
che vuoi essere bravo ma devo ammettere
ma le cose che si sono fatti così
correnti noi andiamo a girare questa
ruota in pasta il futuro capite ad
esempio meno due buoni
due di questi rimuovere due di questi
sperando che il contenuto piacere
all'interno un caso sulla destra adesso
fuoco erano dobbiamo o non lo abbiamo
parlato e scritto prima perché possono
quando si toglie uno di uno di questi
potrebbe potrebbe far partire il
meccanismo che altri sul territorio a
cadere sul palco sud
ok speriamo che ha capito e stenti
capitolo capire una cosa che si beretta
le cose in testa ma non sony stessa sarà
troviamo maglietta bianca prof
secondo voi chi perderà a chi capiterà
schifezza sé stessa guardatemi
istruzione ha lasciato bella questa
challenge se volete vederne altre come
sempre per 10.000 andremo a fare in
altre sale insieme insieme
scrivetelo pure nei commenti romero
allora mi farebbe fare era un di cui
cambieremo la cosa che mettiamo destro
per il primo round
abbiamo mettere acqua con il colore
frisini quale quello che allora è un
quell'acqua andiamo a mettere il
colorante tanta
[Musica]
il mio senso di cappelli aiuto per
adattare applicabili su di te e che ti
colori la barba tutta verde sta cadendo
giù vero sembra andiamo oltre un'altra
goccia tenta tutti diventa ancora più
scura che ho fatto
vuoi chiedere coerenza tuo vinta perché
io ok nega che ci stiamo inizialmente
prego almeno 101
insomma sì ho visto qualcosa non è
successo niente qualficazione notare c'è
un pezzo quindi e caso proprio di sì a
chi utilizza turno no che adesso l'ho
sentito qualche goccia di quelli là
allora non si fregiavano per tutto ma si
avvertono che i ragazzi penso che questo
gioco si apprende di kakà beckham e
locate
[Musica]
[Applauso]
zero non certo per la bastarda non so
perché perde un po forse difettoso e una
punizione in più non vederle in più
meno uno insomma caffè
[Musica]
ma perché perdono spesso non ci crea lo
zero teniamo riuscito me ne vado con
questo non siamo neppure di me non è
d'aiuto pacate mi scoccio un po ma non
capisco perché perde lo stesso meno uno
[Musica]
dai che capitate dai speriamo di no si
ritira meno due
dio ha detto la possibilità se ranocchia
[Musica]
no questa volta di stabilità messo
l'anello debole che quindi anche un
nuovo talento tutto fra i non ti
preoccupare adesso c'è un altro nome
frenare nuovamente neppure io ok
prepariamo nuovamente la macchina delle
strutture e questa volta cambiamo un
colore che mi ha portato senato ok
allora abbiamo già un pò di vertemati
gioco incluse
perciò mi rovinerà la maglietta se mi
cadde addosso quindi un semplicissimo
vabbè dai sinistro perché è chiaro cosa
che una ballario questo è terribile non
ci credo quando è brutto studio bozzetto
dai tre ne abbiamo piazzato abbiamo
controllato tutto ma scusate ma se detto
da qualche gocciolina non mi avevo già
preso tutto addosso
meno uno dai caffè
[Musica]
però non si può sapere
meno uno dai tema che fortuna anche se
lo fanno perché nel frattempo stiamo
subendo comunque all'avventura stata
beccata terribile trovando dappertutto
ecco allora per il terzo round il
colorante sarà nero quindi è troppo però
[Applauso]
sapete come al solito basta
petrolio sembra inchiostro di un pezzo
sarà percepire la spagnola letta il
bagnetto caffè e di perderanno i
coincidono scuse a tutta ciao
[Musica]
tutto quanto è ovviamente mi sono messo
così tanto meno ci diamo la caccia e la
pesca corso dei mesi capite sono
riuscito 0 darei giorno c'è un colono
[Applauso]
prima mi sa che fortuna la regola come è
possibile che ti capitato il brano è una
fortuna adesso ci va della mia batte a
soffrire di vento credo uno di meno
[Musica]
[Applauso]
oh mio dio che si è mantenuta
[Musica]
non può coprire occhio perché diventata
blu
sì perché è perché non è successo già
due volte no vorrei che certamente sente
una bella doccia sgrassante ressa come
[Musica]
dico io perché ciò l'ha progettata scura
l'acquisizione del previsto tutto da che
vorresti dire la nottata ragazzi non è
finita qua perché abbiamo l'ultimo round
di misano abbiamo 19 ragazzi il quarto è
la prima
latte rimangono gravi perché noi non
cambiamo la medina che beffa a chi
capita no ma lo ripeto è anzitutto
perché l'inter è pronto a rendere
battezzato mancano il coso cosa di pioli
ha peccato quando siano infondate
risulterebbe stato fantastico
allora sei pronto al battesimo di
mandorle
ecco fatto 222 idricamente il potere
delle mafie m12 vai
meno primo 45 possibilità che possa
capitare a me quando i sistemi per il
modello ma questo questo round finisce 1
a 1
perché 2
[Musica]
faccioli società oh mio dio disastrosa
bello segue pelle c'è ancora il latte di
mandorla e non ci posso credere che è
andata peggio a mediaset aggiunge
qualche ha subiti su facciamo veramente
malefica chiunque l'abbia inventata noi
[Musica]
a parte ma nel latte ho fatto le chiazze
bianche l'ho detto cioè per setacciato
già non mi fare il film missione di più
peter straughan fip disastrosa e
traumatiche e tutto il merito per terra
stai facendo il funk top ultimo
veramente consegnateci pure nei commenti
attrezzate in giudizio fronte che una
tale e non da fare con questo è un po
basta con domenica per me io ho cambiato
colore completamente ho iniziato bianca
e sono diventata c'era lei non
sopportato questo progetto scuola aprire
la cina ad allora tutti come l'aig se vi
è piaciuta carta challenge infatti si
sta perché al momento mi ha divertito di
più è la tesi timestamp nei commenti e
ora vi lasciamo ba 4 badr a fini su cui
potete cliccare perché
inoltre altri talenti con nostri video
divertenti i nostri nuovi video kick ass
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao